the single most striking thing I've
learned so far in my career as a
scientist is that the ultimate nature of
reality whatever it is it is just much
weirder than we thought
much more different from what we thought
it was then people in their wildest
dreams would have imagined in the past
no we used to think well there's this
stuff you know it moves in certain ways
certain properties and like this is
solid this is a bit squishy is red you
know and and gradually I think we've
come to the conclusion that all of this
is governed by these mathematical rules
which are very much like what you would
experience if we were actually inside of
a video game yeah you know if you were
pac-man or something and started to
study your pac-man world you discover
not only is stuff moving around it has
certain properties but the things that
you first thought had some sort of a
philosophical physical nature are all
behaving according to simple
mathematical rules you'd be basically
rediscovering the source code that the
programmer had put in there yes right
and that first sounds kind of nutty when
you say it and then in my mathematical
or mathematical universe the book I even
go as far as saying our universe isn't
just described by math it is
mathematical in the sense of being a
mathematical structure by which I mean
that our universe doesn't just have some
mathematical properties it has only
mathematical properties yes much like a
computer game
that sounds very nutty so let's break it
down a little bit like if you take an
object like this book for example well
it seems like it has a lot of very non
mathematical properties it's bend the
ball and that's a paper smell and that's
different colors so those don't seem
like mathematical properties at all
right my
mom and many with her think your math
basically is a sadistic form of torture
the schoolteachers have invented that to
make us feel bad about ourselves or
maybe as a bag of tricks for
manipulating numbers but like what
properties of this book are numbers well
there's a three here but that tells us
nothing about the nature of reality it's
just I decided to put it there right but
if you look more closely what you
actually have here it seen through my
physics eyes is a big blob of electrons
and quarks and what properties does an
electron have -1 1/2 1 and so on and
even though we physicists have given
these properties nerdy names like the
electric charge the spin and they look
the lepton number they're just numbers
right the only difference between an
electron and a quark as far as we can
tell are what those corresponding
numbers are and in fact all the
particles that make just everything in
the world here are described by the
different sets of these these numbers
and space itself that all of this stuff
is in you know what properties this
space have 3 as a property of space
that's the largest number of fingers I
can hold that are all perpendicular to
each other again you know we came up
with a nerdy name for this the
dimensionality of space but it's a
number and Einstein discovered some more
properties of space called curvature and
topology which are also things
mathematicians study and if ultimately
everything in space as well as space
itself has only mathematical properties
then it starts to sound a little bit
less than saying that yes actually we
own this living in this gigantic
mathematical object